[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonjour à tous je m'appelle games dites
moi dans vos langues
est ce que vous le nom signifie quelque
chose est ce que vous voulez savoir ce
que signifie mon nom dans mon pas toi
dans ma langue mon baume veut dire
certains dans n'importe quel certains
serpents boas
je vois tout de suite que votre regard a
changé
oui je m'appelle game boy je suis
passionné de tout ce qui est
communication voyage culture découverte
l'an dernier je suis tombée amoureuse du
bénin j'ai voulu marcher sur les traces
de nos ancêtres en empruntant le chemin
des esclaves
j'ai voulu fouler du pied la porte du
non retour
devinez quoi je les fais et à deux mois
j'ai visité cet incroyable pays j'étais
à ouidah j'ai essayé de comprendre les
croyances locales
j'ai parlé aux divinités telles que
heroes coco ou encore le dieu du fer
j'ai expérimenté un tendre dont attendez
j'ai porté un certain imaginez un
serpent vous rampant dessus s'enroule
autour de votre cou se faufilant le long
de votre corps ses yeux brillants ne
regardait un musée sa peau était glacée
c'est incroyable j'ai adoré j'ai
tellement adoré que j'ai partagé sur mes
réseaux sociaux bon vous savez il faut
vivre bien l'air de son temps n'est ce
pas j'étais surtout fier d'avoir pris
d'une culture qui plus est une culture
africaine
je me suis d'ailleurs promise de revenir
1 10 janvier vous savez vous quoi la
fête du vaudou 1
malheureusement les bonnes choses ayant
une fin
je suis retourné au cameroun à peine
deux jours de mon arrivée
mon téléphone sonne c'est ma mère au
bout du fil elle se met à crier d'une
voie esthétique mais qu'est ce que tu as
fait du oui qu'est ce que je fais est un
problème
elle me dit tu as posté une photo ou une
vidéo
toi sur facebook ou supporter un serpent
et ça ne semble pas du tout gêné je lui
ai pu effectivement j'essaie de lui
expliquer avec sur l'expérience je
voulais retransmettre la grenade avait
ressenti lorsque j'étais dans ce moment
là ma mère m'a coupé
angie on a montré cette photo est cette
vidéo à ta grand mère
depuis hier elle ne cesse de pleurer
ge a eu la même réaction
je me suis demandé pourquoi ma
grand-mère plus rien qu'est ce qui avait
bien pu la traumatiser et ma mère me dit
on lui a dit le monde nos sociétés
africaines là on lui a dit que tu fait
désormais partie d'une secte d'adeptes
de serpents et que dans la vidéo tu
prononce une phrase d'allégeance à votre
gourou ouah c'est typiquement ça on est
tout de suite dans l'exagération n'est
ce pas déjà que ma grand mère née sous
aucun réseau social
en plus elles ne parlent aucune autre
langue que leone qui est notre langue
maternelle
elle a toujours refusé d'apprendre les
langues étrangères qu'elle considère
comme la langue du colonisateur
par quel miracle dont aurait-elle pu
avoir accès à cette vidéo ou bien qui a
bien pu lui donner une interprétation
aussi erronée de la situation et qu'elle
l'eût cru j'observais quelques secondes
de silence et j'ai dit à ma mère je te
rappelle je me suis plongé dans une
introspection
je me suis demandé à quel moment de
notre histoire
avons-nous rejeté notre culture à quel
moment l'avant nous fait sombrer dans
l'oubli
le dénigrement au point d'en perdre
notre identité notre africanité etc
question existentielle m'est venu à
l'esprit parce que avant que je repose
ma question de vous à moi
bon mon nom serpent est ce que ça
devrait autant choqué que j'emporte
voilà et l'acte existentielle ci-après
m'est venu à l'esprit pourquoi en
sommes-nous arrivés là
pourquoi il existe au cameroun un peu
appelé les belges luc et les belles
équipes pratiquent un rituel qu'ils
appellent et au qu'il considère le culte
des crânes bon c'est vrai que quand on
dit comme ça beaucoup de choses me
viennent à l'esprit pour les bamiléké il
est essentiel d'entretenir les crânes de
leurs de fin pour éviter tout ce qui est
mauvais présage pour éviter la maladie
pour éviter que les esprits ne soient
mécontents et pourrait vite également la
mort pour le blick et être en contact
avec un crâne humain sait communiquer
avec la malheureusement avec l'avènement
de l'évangélisation et par ricochet du
christianisme
de plus en plus ceux qui pratiquent ce
rituel sont pointés du doigt la nouvelle
génération c'est à dire vous et moi nous
retrouvons tiraillé entre eux religions
et traditions
monseigneur what you qui est un évêque
soit dit en passant et qui a consacré
des travaux occultes haut du crâne
disait que bien avant l'arrivée de
l'évangélisation les dames les quais
priait dieu existe chez les dames les
quais il continue en disant qu' il est
possible de respecter cette tradition de
parler à nos morts sans se sentir
coupable
par exemple faisons tous dans l'histoire
sur dix a taclé ita leroy madang on
l'appelait l'enfant lion n'est ce pas
nos équipes sportives portent des noms
d'animaux
les lions indomptables les éléphants de
côte d'ivoire les écureuils cela ne
choque personne n'est ce pas simplement
parce qu'il est
dans nos moeurs de vénérer les divinités
de la nature aujourd'hui si quelqu'un
dit dans sa communauté qu'il va dans son
village pour un rique de protection ou
de purification il sera tout de suite
taxé de qualificatifs dont je tairai le
nom on va dit sorcellerie sept ans
rejette désormais notre culture on se
perd dans les méandres de la
mondialisation et de la modernité avec
leurs travers on oublie qu'ils nous
sommes nous africains
l'africanité parlons-en c'est un terme
qui est née après les indépendances dans
les années 50 et 60 et qui caractérise
tout ce qui relève de la culture et de
la société africaine
qu'est ce que nous allons léguer à nos
enfants
s'ouvrir au monde c'est bien mais pègre
ses racines c'est désastreux
pourquoi parce qu'on a peur parce qu'on
ne sait plus parce que on a honte ou
simplement parce que on a subi un lavage
de cerveau qui nous fait croire que ceux
qui dans le passé était acceptée est
pratiqué aujourd'hui est mal vue est
taxé de sorcellerie les 3èmes ont été
utilisés par le colon pour assujettis
notre peuple
quand on parle de 3 m il s'agit des
marchands ils nous ont fait boire de
l'eau de vie nous ont donné des
cigarettes pour nous endormir
il s'agit des militaires ils ont fait
preuve de force ils ont utilisé les
armes pour nous envahir
il s'agit des missionnaires jomo
kenyatta disais tantôt lorsque les
blancs sont arrivés en afrique nous
avions les terres et la bid
ils nous ont appris à prier les yeux
fermés
lorsqu'on a ouvert les yeux il avait les
terre et nous la bible
on peut désormais se défaire de ce lourd
passé juste avec un peu d'objectivité
gaston kelman disait
le problème est moins la colonisation
que ce que l'africain a fait après il ne
s'agit pas de rejeter complètement notre
culture ou de juger toute personne qui
tente une immersion culturelle et
traditionnelle
il s'agit de faire de notre africanité
une force un atout pourquoi ne pas par
exemple apprendre les mathématiques en
fonte amant barras orlov en swahili en
lingala un niveau d'eau et j'en passe
non ce n'est pas sauvage pourquoi ne pas
apprendre à nos enfants les yeux de nos
grands rois tels que le faisaient les
griots ses gardiens de la tradition
on pourrait par exemple accès
exclusivement nos programmes scolaires
depuis la maternelle
en passant par le primaire et même le
secondaire sur notre histoire sur nos
pays une autre mère l'afrique le
meilleur lait pour un enfant est celui
provenant de sa mère dit un proverbe
wolof
alors nous qui voulons contribuer au
développement de notre pays
quand je dis notre pays je parle de
l'afrique parce que l'afrique
c'est un vaste pays nous qui voulons
donc impacter nous qui voulons
développer notre continent devrions
garder à l'esprit que les solutions à
proposer soit des innovations sociales
c'est-à-dire des solutions adaptées à
notre contexte et qui doivent répondre à
un besoin de façon efficace et de façon
créative
j'ai pris mon temps d'introspection
ça m'a pris deux semaines vous imaginez
un peu le niveau de réflexion j'ai
rappelé ma mère et je lui ai dit je suis
fier de porter ce nom je veux retourner
dans mon village à prendre ma langue je
veux a pas à prendre ma culture je
m'appelle banques qui sait peut-être de
serpents c'est mon totem
oui je m'appelle galles bon je ne peux
que vous inviter au cameroun où venir
dans mon pays
car je suis une habitante du vaste pays
qu'est l'afrique mais j'habite un petit
quartier appelé le cameroun je vous
invite donc dans mon quartier manger la
sauce d'arachide avec durée boire une
bonne rasade du vin de palme parler aux
anciens de chez moi vous senti chez vous
chez nous je suis certes catholique mais
j'ai soif d'apprendre de l'afrique car
je suis africaine mais pas encore sortir
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]